boom pal pop those are the sounds you
can expect to hear all across the valley
as we celebrate america's birthday with
several fireworks shows happening like
you mentioned all across the valley
including tomorrow night at palace
station but as always it's important to
know the risks at hand when lighting up
first and foremost if you are going to
celebrate with fireworks this fourth of
july make sure they are the permitted
ones aka safe and sane ones you may have
seen stands around town that which sell
fireworks permitted in the city of las
vegas and clark county these fireworks
do not fly up in the air or explode and
they don't move rapidly across the
ground however they do have a lot of
light and effect and most of them are
entertaining and most importantly safe
even so las vegas fire and rescue shares
some must haves to have handy in case
any flare-ups occur
my expectations are that it will be
windy
and that we will get
a lot of fires we recommend that people
have a garden hose standing by for any
spot fires and that they have a
bucket of water or two so that they can
pick up the fireworks after they're
spent
nolan also says it's vital that if you
need to report illegal fireworks you go
to
ispyfireworks.com that's the letter i
and do not call 9-1-1 as for those who
use illegal fireworks within city limits
you're looking at a minimum fine of 250
dollars and those who use within the
county will pay even more with a minimum
fine of 500 dollars the fireworks show
here starts at 9 p.m tomorrow here at
palace station it's free and open to the
public for a full list of different
locations across the valley having
fireworks shows you can head to our
website at 8newsnow.com reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now